e
good afternoon everyone um my name is
Kathy stab I'm the chair of this
committee and I'm going to call this
committee to study the impact of the
housing crisis on people with
disabilities to order and I would invite
my uh two colleagues to introduce
themselves why don't you begin Senator
oh good afternoon everyone I'm Denise
rardy and state senator for District 9
and I'm so thrilled to be part of this
very important committee and have
and representative Jessica lontine from
Dover
and I'm glad to be here working on this
committee also thank yes and you're the
clerk yes and I'm the
clerk okay so we have something new
today um the um the meeting is being
recorded and you know it's being
broadcast so that you know people that
who can't are are unable to make it can
um want me to pull that forward a little
bit how about that um so um people who
are um unable to make it are still able
to follow along with what's happening in
the um do we have a
extra okay um follow along with with
what we're doing um and uh so um
speaking from experience all I have to
say is that if you're in the witness
protection program or you don't want
people seeing the faces that you make
when somebody says something don't agree
with then don't sit right behind the
speaker because I've done that and
regretted it when I watched the replay
all right um and we have whoops can I
have that thing over here all right yeah
there we go um uh representative would
today
uh yeah sure um my name is
representative joshu Kella I am
representing
representing uh Rockingham 32 districts
of uh includes Fremont Danville and
brenwood all right thank you okay so we
have a uh um we don't have a lot of uh
people presenting today but we have a
big presentation um from New Hampshire
housing um so I would uh invite you to
come forward and um uh you know let's
let's hear what you have to say and
hopefully you'll be able to answer some
lot do you want to bring extra chairs up
go right ahead if you all want to do
this good
afternoon pleasure to be back uh I was
with the committee for your second
meeting um and spoke with you and
answered some questions
um yeah can you please State your state
your names for the for the clerk sure
for the record my name is Jack
rudderman energy and legislative affairs
advisor at New Hampshire Housing and
with me today are my colleagues ignacius
mclen who is the managing director of
our multif family housing division and D
pulot who is the managing director of
the assisted housing
division as I was saying at the last uh
meeting that I attended did I provided
as much information as I could uh on the
questions that were on the committee's
mind but there were questions relating
to um multif family housing and also
housing Choice vouchers um that uh were
sort of Beyond uh not not in my
wheelhouse uh and so we promised to come
back with people who could give you more
details on those questions so I guess I
would just kick it off by asking which
would you like to hear about first um
the the multif family or the um or the
housing choice or the vouchers what's
your
please hope you can hear me okay yes we
can thank you so New Hampshire housing
administers the federal HUD housing
Choice voucher program we are one of 18
house local housing authorities in the
state who also administer the housing
toys voucher program a couple of the
questions that Jack had asked me about
are the total number of vouchers in the
state and there are
11,297 um total vouchers in the state
administered by those like local housing
authorities New Hampshire housing we
have
just over 4,000 vouchers that we
administer and we have a budget from HUD
of about $50 million to administer those
vouchers the total money that comes to
the state the 2024 calendar year
Statewide budget Authority from HUD was
um
$27.4
million that comes to the state for each
housing authority to administer its
voucher
program thank you
of of our um voucher participants at New
Hampshire housing I don't have this I
don't have the other Housing Authority
numbers because they're all independent
housing authorities but at New Hampshire
housing 78% of our voucher holders are
disability about 10% are elderly and 68%
are persons with a
disability on our waiting list we have
just under 12,000 applicants on the
waiting list and
6,300 of those are elderly or have a
disability the bulk um over 4,000 are
persons with a disability waiting for a
voucher yep do you have those can you
send those to those numbers to us in the
email it will make make it a lot easier
for us thank you but thank you go ahead
uh the estimated wait time for the
majority of
um applicants on the waiting list is 6
to8 years it's probably going
up we do have um HUD allows each housing
authority to set its preferences and
priority of your waiting list um at New
Hampshire housing we have two priority
preferences and that weight time um is
now running about 1 to two years and
those priority preferences are for
applicant with a terminal illness or an
applicant who is um re who is eligible
for one of the four Medicaid waiver
programs and that weight time is about
now we only can pull from the waiting
list as vouchers become available so
it's all based on attrition and the
attrition right now is very low all our
vouchers are in
use attritions very low as people go off
the program we can add new households
from the waiting
list um New Hampshire housing is one one
of a couple other housing authorities in
New Hampshire we are what HUD calls
we're in
shortfall the rents are so high some of
the rents are so high that we we have to
live within our I'm just say $50 million
budget so as our average subsidy cost
goes up we have to serve less or start
to just slow down we don't anticipate
pulling from the waiting list through
the rest of this calendar year which
will only increase the wait times for
the majority of applicants on the
waiting
list is that that y um Happ to answer
questions yeah go ahead Senator rich I
have two questions I just want to make
sure that I'm clear on something you
said a terminant ill person has a
two-year
weight I mean one to two years right now
because of the funding situation we're
in Prior years um it was less than a
month we were pulling every month I
we're just in you know HUD it's just
based on our HUD funding we're we're
dependent on the HUD budget he follow up
go ahead so in a perfect world how would
you suggest fixing
this well the HUD budget is based on
Congressional
Appropriations we haven't seen basically
many new vouchers appropriated through
Congress last year we received some
vouchers for under um for veterans you
know this HUD has what they call special
purpose vouchers so you can compete and
apply for vouchers as they become
available as appropriated by through
Congress so as a state that isn't this
is you have to talk to the federal
delation to ask for them to do
something correct it's federally funded
dependent on the federal program reach
year um does anyone else have any
questions okay representative
yella hi thank you um
so I assume that the um that the waiting
list is a Statewide list um and not each
of the
18 um agencies have their own list right
and so how or do you no that's just our
that's just New Hampshire housing's
waiting list each Housing Authority in
addition has its own waiting list we may
have the same applicants on each other's
list but NASA Manchester all each
Housing Authority has its own waiting
list um okay so you have 12,000 waiting
on your list but that's not the entire
that's just us yes that's just you we
work Statewide so when I say the
Statewide waiting list because we
operate
Statewide so how are
the
11,000 vouchers kind of divvied up are
is it equally well I assume it can't be
equally since you have almost
like a
third of the of all of the vouchers so
how how is that kind of divvied up and
and um so the people on your waiting
list are waiting for one of your
vouchers that are currently assigned to
someone to be not utilized
anymore right so HUD allows us to set
each housing authority to set its own
preference system so like I said we have
the two higher preferences and then our
next group which we're going to say is
the six to eighty year group that is for
applicants who are homeless pay more
than 50% of their income for rent living
in substandard housing victims of
domestic violence or
veterans they that's the bulk of the
waiting list that's the bulk probably
eight or ,000 applicants and that and
then the rest of the applicants don't
have a preference they don't meet any of
the
above okay
go
ahead so um your your choices for
preferences um those aren't a Statewide
thing right so the 18 other or 17 other
um agencies could have other preferences
um most have got I'm sorry are you aware
of what the any of those preferences are
the V uh are there a variety or or do
you believe that they're pretty much the
same just in speaking with them and we
all have to have a HUD approved
administrative plan and it's a public
document so they all could be looked up
from what I hear from the other housing
authorities they have simplified their
preference system to um some have done
away with preferences the local housing
authorities often have a residency
preference that you come before somebody
who if you live in Nashville you might
come before somebody who doesn't live in
nashwa they can have a residency
preference uh had allows that
some of the housing authorities um
they've tried to simplify their
preferences I would say but they they
could be similar to ours um the other
little kind of information of the
preferences regardless of the
preferences HUD requires that 75% of the
turnover vouchers each year go to
applicants who are extremely lwi income
and those are applicants who are at 30%
or below of the area median income limit
so regardless of the preference you
still have to meet that mandatory
vouchers so it's basically um sort of
acts like a preference some at times so
and I know that conquer do maybe Summers
worth they have closed their waiting
list because the list becomes so long
applicants um go ahead
representative L and could you explain
you said that um one of your other
priorities are those eligible for the
the waiver program and how do those two
programs work together the voucher with
the waiver program it gives them a
preference so if they're eligible in
receiving services on one of the four
Medicaid waiver programs which um is
choices for Independence nursing home
eligible care uh developmentally
disabled brain
[Music]
injury home support oh home support for
children um those four Medicaid waiver
they're they're just equal status so
it's date of application and and their
Medicaid um waiver eligibility form okay
so it's just a status that they're yeah
so they get a higher wait on the waiting
list um the right now just for that
preference there are over 300 applicants
on the waiting list claiming one of
those Medicaid waiver
programs okay um I have a question um
where can we get a list of the um 18 um
other agencies we can send that to you
thank you it's on our website as well
but we'll make it easy and send that to
you thank you take um the other question
that I i' I'd like you to address is
that um can you um give us uh you know I
uh there may be people that watch this
um who are unfamiliar with how the
vouchers work and my understanding is
that there are the housing Choice
vouchers which you know you can use to
um get an apartment in a private
building and the federal government
subsidizes your rent um but then there
are other vouchers that are specific to
uh um a unit um and how do those work
and um which when we're talking about
you know do you see that we need you
know H how how successful are our people
at getting suitable Apartments using
either housing Choice vouchers or those
um those um vouchers that are the
Section 8 so the housing trades Voucher
Program formerly known as Section 8
right and had tried to move away from
section 8 and call it the housing Choice
voucher program but its brand name is
still Section 8 is easy and with the
voucher program is exactly what you said
you once you get your
voucher you go search for an apartment
we help with the Housing search but it's
the voucher holder's responsibility to
find an apartment or they can use it to
purchase a home they can rent a
manufactured home an apartment a duplex
uh an apartment that has to be uh
suitable for
occupancy be within our rent limits and
pass a minimum housing Quality
Inspection standard and they lease up in
that apartment and we work with those
landlords okay we have had um we've been
able to lease all our vouchers so really
has not been a problem okay the lease up
on the Section 8 when you so we call a
voucher a tenant based program where the
tenant has the subsidy and the Tenant
chooses where they want to live the
other program you're describing is
really and Ignatius is shop but it's
this it's Project based it's the section
A Project based program where HUD gives
those contracts to the property and
ignatius' team they they manage those
contracts but it's Project based so if
you want to move you can't take the
subsidy with you we a voucher you can
take it to Florida we have participants
they could go all over the country it's
transferable so there's this move option
that some people prefer to have the
choice
okay all right okay um can I ask um like
we're mostly interested in um and and
this may be um not specific to um the
voucher system but um I know that um New
Hampshire housing also does a lot of
data collection on rent rates and Etc um
and I
just wondered do you have
do you maintain any data of like how
many people with disabilities are using
these vouchers and well you've given us
some but you know what how many how many
do we have say say Project based how
many do we have how many could we use
and um you know um what are the um I
don't know what what are the in
incentives are actually building proper
properties that will um accommodate
people who have physical disabilities or
um other
disabilities so we really without the
voucher um there were no new section A
contracts HUD HUD um ended that program
in the early 80s um 1980s ended that
program so there were no new
project-based contracts oh okay um so
with the vouchers any any housing that
New Hampshire housing developed and
finances the owner of that property
cannot say no to vouchers so voucher
holders can certainly go into any
housing um financed and and administered
by New Hampshire housing okay all right
representative
lantin do you think that um HUD would
consider Project
based ones if it was only a portion of
the building that's set aside for people
with disability say in which they
weren't creating a whole building for
yep they I guess I should have clarified
a little bit more on that project base
there's a you can project base vouchers
so we actually are allowed by Hud to
take some of our
vouchers and project base them in one of
those
properties um and we have done that so
we can project base we cannot Project
based vouchers for a specific disability
it would be a violation of fair
housing so it might be people with
disabilities have it can apply and come
from our waiting list and go into those
properties but we wouldn't necessarily
have a project based vouchers for a
project representative
yella yes thank you
there was
some where that I had heard that if
someone got a
voucher um that they had trouble
finding housing in New Hampshire um that
would meet it but then you also stated
that all of them are least and so I
guess my question is how many of
them well I guess it's kind of twofold
how
[Music]
many structures do you believe
um
are currently let's say on the market
that fall within
your um
rent cap right and then also how many of
the
people uh if any do you have you seen
not be able to find housing and they're
out in their time frame that they're
allowed to find it and have to surrend
it so those are great questions um I
don't know how many buildings or
properties we have vouchers in we have
2100 landlords for the 4,000 or so
vouchers so we have you know large
properties with multiple voucher
participants in it so we have 2100
landlords and the success rate which is
also measured by Hud how many vouchers
does it take to get one lease up and
it's about the success rate is about
70% so all our vouchers are in use but
that's because we might issue three
vouchers we might notify three people
from the waiting list for one voucher
knowing that two may not be eligible or
successful within their Housing search
time so they have 120
days and then they can ask for an
extension um if they need more time but
there not everybody is successful either
the vulture could expire or
they give give give up or you know they
don't find anything it could be uh we we
work with each vure holder to track the
barriers so what is preventing them from
leasing up is it credit is it criminal
record is it they need a first floor
they need a one-bedroom they have a
service animal all you know all the
reasons that we work with them through
those barriers to want them to be
successful with their voucher lease up
successful
so um I'm interested in if you're
tracking
um that the let's say that the um
the the property is not
useful like we've heard a lot about like
Universal Design and stuff like that
about it's it doesn't have meet their
needs as far as they're disabled and
they can't um whether it be first floor
or some other you know you know curbless
shower or something like that that needs
um that the that the person would need
um if you're tracking those um don't if
they have more no we don't track them if
they we know like in the um properties
financed by New Hampshire housing we
know properties financed by New
Hampshire housing have accessible units
in them so we would refer them to apply
to these specific propert where we know
they might have units that meet their
needs they also in the private Market
they could make those modifications work
with the landlord to make those
modifications but we wouldn't we only
track we only would know those that we
have it as a barrier that they're you
know looking for a unit that they need
that is um accessible and barrier free
we would refer them to the list of
Apartments we know about okay and and
for someone you notify three people for
a single voucher and
um I guess if the two people that are
not
successful um in 120
days do they go back on the waiting list
and they get a notified again what they
start the search over again or they just
off of the list and go back to the end
of the line and start you know their
sixy year weight over again all that um
they if they're actively looking and get
an extension we're very generous with
extension
um you can get extension as long as we
have a voucher available and through
attrition we usually can but they have
to be actively looking in their Housing
search because it's holding up another
slot in the event that either they go
away or we don't hear from them for
several weeks or a month we inactivate
the their we inactivate their status and
then they would have to reapply and go
as a follow up on that what if you
notify three people that there's a
voucher available and two of them are
successful in finding apartment then
what do you do we would like all three
to be sucessful um because then we we
have a forecasting tool and we're when
the next month we look at attrition and
we decide how many slots do we have and
then we say oh how many leased up how
many didn't how many are searching so
every month we have um a forecasting
tool that takes us through so so we know
maybe this month we pulled 10 people or
20 people or no one was successful um
sometimes they're living already living
in their where they want to stay they're
in place so that's easy so we can count
on that right away in our forecasting so
it's always looking at who went on who
went off and and balancing it HUD gives
us the whole calendar year so as long as
the end of the calendar year we don't
exceed our voucher count you you kind of
have some wiggle room if you're a little
high one month you use through attrition
you'll balance yourself
out okay um from what I understand HUD
uses the area median rent or they they
develop some sort of a formula for what
they consider a an acceptable price to
pay for an apartment do you have what
how does that compare with what uh
landlords are actually charging so HUD
publishes its fair market rents each
year effective October 1st they they
were just published last um last month
for October 1st and housing authorities
have 90 days to set what HUD calls a
payment standard that's our subsidy
standard so we have a fair market rent
We compare it to the rent study that you
were talking about you know that um New
Hampshire housing completes each a rent
study We compare it to the low-income
housing tax credit program rent so we're
looking to see what's what is the
comparable Market rent and H gives the
Housing Authority we have the permission
to set that okay between 80 and
120% um we have a waiver to 120% some
housing authorities can only go to 110%
but we have that flexibility to set that
as we're trying to set it close to
Market because if if we find our success
rate dropping we look at the rents okay
and then we want to know why aren't they
leasing up I this um H only pays us if
they lease up so it doesn't do us any
good to have a lot of voucher holders
searching and they're unable to lease up
so we're looking at what are the
barriers again if rent's a
barrier then um and we can go in some
cases we can go over 120% of the fair
market rent as a reasonable
accommodation for an applicant with a
disability we have to get approval from
HUD Washington okay all right so what
you're saying is like if um HUD says the
or is 100
no uh $1,200 a month say is is an
acceptable rent you're able to go 20%
above that and and and have a a voucher
that would accommodate that level of
rent okay and we're always trying to do
that within that $50 million budget so
we can't give everybody 120% we wouldn't
have enough money so we're looking at
setting we're trying to set our payment
reasonable can you would before we let
you go um others may have other
questions but who are the people that
are coming looking for
vouchers so our waiting list is made up
mostly um by with people with disability
um elderly or they're on the list so
long they become
elderly um families with
children um are really I would say um
applicants with a disability make up
most of use most of the vouchers and
make up most of the waiting
list and and how do they come to you oh
sorry they uh they can apply through our
website they work with a lot of the area
agencies or working with um you know if
they're applying for City benefits
welfare benefits they may ask them you
know refer them to the local Housing
Authority as well as as ours and the
same with us if someone calls us they
apply with us but we may also say apply
with the local Housing Authority you can
apply with more than
one okay okay all right representative
lontine and then representative
yella uh do the private property owners
that um rent to these vouches do they
also get a tax credit for doing that not
not under the voucher program no
y well if the city does one it's not
through us we wouldn't know about it if
the town or city offers some tax
incentive we wouldn't know about
it but as far as you know they don't get
a federal tax no no no not federal for
ahead so we had um a
number of
people um well you said 300 people are
able to accept
one of these waivers that are on the on
the waiting list so 300 out of the
11,000
yes
um I'm just
uh I'm I'm you but you said that there's
a significant portion of the people
um
are either using or on the waiting list
um do you have any information about um
the whether it's an intellectual or
physical disability um
or I guess that yeah because there there
seems to be a lot of
um 300 just seems small as out of 11,000
if 300 for us is high on that Medicaid
waiver yeah yeah um but it could be
small but that's just under those
Medicaid W you know that's just really
Medicaid waiver and that mostly when
when they come to the top it's usually
under the DD waiver the for
developmentally disabled it's usually
that waiver program but everybody else
on the waiting list that um says they're
disabled by law we can't ask we don't
know the nature of their disability so
it could be just they receive um
SSDI right we've we've been getting a
lot of statistics and a lot of them are
are are specifically saying like
developmentally disabled people are in
the statistics and not essentially all
disabled people um and
so it seems like your numbers are more
going to be in the everyone category and
not specifically broken out as far as
dis developmentally versus physically
dis
right the only one we would know is if
it's a Medicaid waiver it's the only
disability we know because they come
under that waiver program all right
thank you very much welcome do we have
any more questions
for um um I'd like to um uh hear from um
Mr mclen now about the uh
multi Slide
the about about what what your Miler is
all right good afternoon so I'm ignacius
mclen I'm the managing director of the
multifam housing team at New Hampshire
housing I'll leave my card for the
spelling on my way out so the multif
family housing team runs the Housing
Finance programs for new production and
the Housing Finance programs for
purchase
Rehabilitation or or just straight um
recapitalization
and
Rehabilitation and we do that primarily
using the federal programs of the
lowincome housing tax credit
program the home partnership program
Housing Trust Fund and the state
affordable housing fund and the recently
the invest in h money through Bea we've
um worked with Bea very closely to get
their funds into a lot of the new
production that we have been part of um
Bea business and economic Affairs okay
Taylor Caswell and his team and what I
what I wrote down just so you don't have
to keep all the notes after this meeting
we will send you a grid that explains
the programs okay we'll send you our
annual report and we'll send you our
program plan which if you just look at
the multif family information and D's
information will be in there it'll give
you a good overview so I only prepared
notes because once you take a step into
Housing Finance it has so many layers of
complexity um but think about it when
you go for production we have a
production program using the the 9%
Federal lowincome housing tax credit
program which is simple and complicated
it gets private investors to put money
into the house
in exchange for long-term tax credits
and other tax benefits and then the home
program the Housing Trust Fund program
and then as I said the state affordable
housing fund and then the invest in age
funds and then there's also debt
associated with the projects depending
on which tax credit program so the 9%
simple way to think about it the 9%
low-income housing tax credit program is
designed that the tax credits would Pro
provide
70% of the cost of land acquisition
engineering approval and actually
building the property and then we have a
4% tax credit program where 30% of the
cost to do all of that is from the tax
credits the challenge is that these all
come with rental restrictions that are
long-term so the short shortest that we
do now we do some 30-year but they're
primarily 45 years and 60 years that
bring income and rent
restrictions which means the properties
cannot support a lot of debt so if I'm
doing Market I'm going to put some money
down I'm going to borrow most of the
money because I can charge the residents
what the market will allow the whole
premise of our programs are you limit
the the rent amount Andor the income
amount which therefore means you can't
build it unless you have what they call
the capital stack and so you can look at
a transaction that might have five
different sources in it so might have
tax credits home HTF affordable housing
Bea and it and each one of those you
should know comes with their own
requirements so on the production side
our goal for both production and
preservation preservation example
conquered Royal Gardens up on the
heights 300 units had not really been
improved for quite a while we did a
major um purchase and recapitalization
where they're gutting the apartments and
bringing them up to more current more
current standards but we'll do about a,
to 1200 units on both the new production
and the purchase and Rehabilitation side
and the reason we do a limited number is
because the subsidies are limited we get
certain allocation from the state we get
a certain allocation um from the fed and
so we then provide those resources
through competitive processes so on the
low-income housing tax credit side on
the 9% we have a thing called the
qualified allocation plan the qap and
that sets out the priorities based on
New Hampshire housing priorities but
also priorities from the public so we
release the qap the qualified allocation
plan and we go through quite a process
in in that um same thing on the 4% tax
credit side we have a notice of funding
opportunity and then we do operate a
separate Supportive Housing Standalone
program um which is a rather small
program because we cannot use the
federal money in in disability specific
housing because as my colleague D
indicated fair housing has some very
significant restrictions on what we can
do with HUD resources you should know
that we have spent quite a time banging
on Hud's door to say if they could read
their regulations in a different way um
and they have not been willing to do
that even though their regulation says
that we should be able to um put forward
a fair housing plan to do some specific
disability housing but we cannot and it
puts a a restriction on both the capital
resources and as D also indicated on
what we can do in terms of
vouchers so in terms of housing for the
disabled I would say a couple things one
we have certain minimums for Ada
American with Disability Act
compliance in the competitive process if
they agree the developer agrees to do
more units we will provide them with
more um points which allows them to
score and they chase the points um and
the like that said the numbers have to
work and I'm going to talk about rental
assistance because if you built
everything without any debt it still
will cost $500 to $700 a month to
maintain an apartment with insurance
maintenance utilities upkeep and and the
like so even if you put somebody into an
apartment that was completely subsidized
there are still long-term carrying costs
um and as as D indicated the a lot of
the folks who are on disability um you
know they're making
$18,000 doll a year and even a third of
that isn't going to really support what
you need to carry to carry it I will say
that within our programs we have this
approach of integration is one of our
number one approaches in terms of
housing for the disabled and it could be
disabled folks could be folks from
homeless it could be income and again we
we lay out okay you get points if you
try to serve these different
populations and then the overlay is you
don't want folks just living integrated
if there aren't Services if they need
services so part of what we do if
somebody gets points for some of these
categories we ask what's your service
plan so that people are successful
because that's what everybody wants is
them to be successful now we do some
Standalone support of housing we're just
about to go to our board with the notice
of funding opportunity for Supportive
Housing but it's small dollars
relatively speaking this year it's a
million and a half to $2 million which
is not a lot of money and that's because
we can only use the State dollars fair
housing won't let us use the federal
dollars and and that has been a
challenge because there a lot of really
good organizations trying to build that
disability specific housing but we
cannot get past the HUD fair housing um
requirement uh let me just go through my
notes the other thing that to go to
representative latin's question about
tax credits the the complicated answer
is it is possible that somebody is
getting tax credits developer comes in
wants to do a 9% tax credit deal they
have agreed um as part of that that
they'll accept folks with disabilities
they'll accept folks with with vouchers
so that so they're not directly because
of that getting the tax credit they're
getting the tax credits as part of the
the development and what we're trying to
do is this holistic housing how do we
take all of these different pieces so as
D indicated housing Choice vouchers have
to be accepted in our properties we do
some project-based vouchers I'll give
you a good example Housing Trust Fund
which is profits from Fanny May and
Freddy Mack you have to serve Folks at
30% area median income they won't even
be able to You Know cover the rent and
so in that case um you need to put
vouchers into those deals so that the
apartment will generate enough rent in
order to carry the apartment cost and
then one other program that New
Hampshire should be very proud of is a
HUD program called section
811 um project-based rental assistance
this is a partnership between New
Hampshire Housing and the State
Department of Health and Human Services
where folks with severe mental illness
are able to get a unit within one of our
projects so it's the same thing you if
you'll put an 811 unit in your project
you'll get a certain number of points so
that's our encouragement and integration
approach I think we've we have and I'll
get the number wrong I think it's
247 currently are out there in the
universe we just applied to HUD
Unfortunately they changed how many we
could apply for but we did get 50 more
and they're small numbers but for
individuals with severe mental illness
and for their families it's something I
think we're we're very we're very proud
of um so I think that's about it you
know we have a we have limited resources
we distribute them through competitive
processes we try our best to include the
disabled as part of that policy but it's
always being balanced against the fact
that New Hampshire is in a severe
housing crisis and I will tell you that
a today a two-bedroom 900 square foot
apartment probably has a total
$370,000 and um so that's why takes a
lot of capital subsidy to get an
apartment that you then have to rent to
so okay senator
first um thank you for uh giving us this
presentation I have a a few things I'm
trying to understand so you know we're
tasked to find solutions to this problem
which it it it's very evident by all the
meetings we've had and listening to
families and listening to all of you
that it's a serious problem but I keep
hearing that a lot of it's tied
federally and when when I'm given a
problem I'm kind of Tenacious and I want
to find a solution and I'm trying to
understand as a state we're hearing the
problems but I'm not being able to grasp
like a real concrete solution um and I
know the housing is like tied to all
this inflation and the economy and all
that um and that so I I want to see if
we can hone in on a real solution that I
can like advocate for or fight for also
um rather than reinvent Wheels is there
any other state that has mastered this
problem I would sure like to know and
how they did it so those are my
questions um well I I can we actually
belong to a national trade Association
the National Conference of State Housing
Finance agencies I can ask the question
about what other states are doing in
terms of this issue housing for the
disabled I will tell you I I know some
of the answer we just got back is that
the state of New Hampshire relative to
other States even within New England
does not put a significant amount of
money into housing um and so I think
part of the solution is going to be
additional State resources but if you
would give me the opportunity Senator to
have a internal discussion about what
some solutions might be because I'm just
ignacius who runs multifamily I work for
Jack and Rob DPP our executive director
and and I have as I sit here I represent
kind of the people of New Hampshire
which is also very diverse in terms of
for-profit nonprofit developers but I
will ask the question about what other
states are doing to see if we can get
some information apprciate that because
I it's important we hear the problems
but I'm I'm not getting a i i we have to
find the solution and some of it can be
legisla but not all of it can be so I we
well thank you yeah thank you
Representative
lontine no I forgot okay sorry so just
to clarify the building cost of 350 to
$370,000 is per unit in a multif family
yes okay and that's very consistent
whether it's a for-profit or a nonprofit
because one of the requirements when you
get our resources you have to put things
out to bid
so that we know that it's competitive
those will vary based on location for
example a green field in gtown for
example May cost less than an infill
urban in downtown Manchester and
sometimes in the northern part of the
state it can cost more because there
y
do you have um an idea of um how many
units are in
process um around the state to you know
I think one thing that people with
disabilities have is that they have very
low incomes so it's hard for them to
compete on the market do do you have any
concept of you know where things are
being built CU you know people with
disabilities want to stay in their
community ities and and how many um
units are um are are recently built or
in process or um and a need has been
identified in a particular Community is
it's a lot to ask no I I I think the
answer is yes um I'll have to figure out
whether we post that information on our
website okay they are required as part
of tenant selection to give folks an
opportunity to apply it's supposed to be
an open process it cannot be a closed
process I know internally we have a list
which I didn't bring with me of all the
units that are under production with us
and where they're located um but but in
terms of is that something that we make
publicly available I have to take I'd
have to take that back and take a look
at
that yeah I so the reason that I ask is
that I'm I'm trying to identify you know
um how many do we need how many do we
have um Coming forward and what is the
gap and how do we address that Gap
um do you have any other questions
yella with
um New Hampshire housing they have uh
they have a bunch of different programs
right
um I
believe some of the programs that you're
talking about when you're talking about
um like that that they're required to
accept vouchers um
is not just projects that you guys
are are kind of spearheading but if
you're
financing um if someone comes to you and
says like hey I want to fin Finance this
this project is that is that the type of
project that you're talking about when
you're talking about like they have they
have to accept the vouchers if they come
to you and say hey we want to finance
this project part of the stipulation of
the loan is that they accept the
vouchers yeah I mean most of the folks
who come to us to develop or purchase
and Rehab yeah um are coming to us
because of our our preferential
financing whether it's access to tax
exempt bonds or it's capital subsidy and
all of them are required to accept
vouchers
um when you're prop when you're uh
giving out the
loans
do you look at or how much it is costing
per unit um as kind of giving them a
better giving them preferential
treatment because obviously if you can
get more
units then your dollar let's say you
have $1 million right if you can if
you're have projects that are
150,000 per unit versus
$350,000 per unit you're going to get a
lot more units and so I guess my
question is are we trying to get the
maximum amount of units out of the
dollars The Limited dollars that you
guys do have or is it kind of just first
come first serve or H how are you
deciding which
projects come first so um everything I
I'll give the an answer to your last
question all of our funds that are
subsidy dollars go through a competitive
process and there's scoring connected to
the competitive process we we try to
look at the cost and we have some
requirements for example we have a
maximum total development cost that is
based on the market and based on the
information so every time we do a
development the cost gets entered into a
database on a per square foot type of
project and um and per and per unit so
that's what Market is telling us that is
what the market and it's not 150 I mean
if we see something at you know two 300
you're like wow this is something this
is good and so yes we look at getting
scarce dollars and getting the most
units there's no question but there are
other considerations I don't know down
in 249 Main Street in nashaa there was
you know an empty space and a lot that
the city really wanted to develop
and so there you're trying to help a
community and you're trying to get
people the ability to live downtown but
it was Urban infill which meant that the
costs were higher and and the like so
the answer is yes we care about TDC we
wish we could control it more but it's
very difficult to control because the
costs are based on the bid process um
and TDC is one thing we look at we look
at other factors such as are you willing
to do more ADA Compliant units that's
too I I just
want to um the sense that I'm getting so
I I understand that that maybe the the
companies that I'm thinking about um
that I've
seen online
that have
um been creating like panelized housing
and getting affordable housing very up
very quickly you know within like a week
they're like built um they're dried in
and and stuff like that they were doing
specific um affordable housing projects
that were in the orders of like $150
$200,000 um for a standalone unit not a
multif
family um but I'm just wondering if if
uh if we're not seeing those types of
projects being
proposed um maybe there's maybe it's
something that I you know should reach
out to that the companies that are doing
that kind of a thing and say hey we
maybe you should apply in in New
Hampshire and and my my concern though
is if they did that maybe they wouldn't
have you know enough points if they're
if they're just being like Oh I'm
building you know a house um if and it's
just you know very affordable that's not
necessarily checking all of your point
boxes that they would then get high on
the list of
funding
um on the list for funding right if
there if someone was specifically
targeting like oh I'm trying to get a
bunch of points so that I can get high
on your your guys's list um how many how
many people um
that are kind of like waiting I guess to
be on your uh to be
funded
that that have a project that maybe
is you know not not very high points but
H how long is their kind of waight or do
they just do they
how long is that waiting list I guess so
we don't do a waiting list we do
everything on a yearly basis although
this year we have awarded points under
the 4% tax exempt on program if you had
a prior application that we ran out of
money so that folks don't wait I will
say like on our 9% which is the big
production program we had 19 developers
submit preliminary applications and that
got Whitted down because they need the
numbers to work and the numbers didn't
work for them and that got whittel down
to um I believe it was 12 and we will
only be able to award four or five
projects a year on the 9% tax credit
side and we have done we have seen
panelized and I will say for the multif
family panelized there may be there's
certainly Time Savings but I'm not sure
the cost savings are that significant so
yeah I I've seen that I've heard that
too
um in C you know certain companies do
different ways um the so what when
you're saying you got you got whittel
down to
12 um that that means that there's 12
developers out there that have some
property that they would like to to you
know develop housing in but we can only
develop housing in four of those those
places
and so there's you know eight places
that we didn't develop or are you
talking about
um yeah I guess that's yes and they
might go from the 9% where they get 70%
tax credit we can work to see can we
switch them over to the 4% where it
takes less Capital subsidy and they get
less credits but they can carry more
debt with higher rents we we try to work
with folks cuz we want to build more
affordable rental homes that's our
that's our number one goal but with the
high cost and limited
resources the all states basically
follow the same not identically the same
but the same competitive
process okay thank you thank you I I
have you have go I have one quick
question do you know what the
differential is in cost between a
regular two-bedroom unit and one with
Universal
Design no but I that's a fair thing for
us to see we can contact for example
Corporation for Supportive Housing and
we can see whether they have that data I
think that's a fair question and the
issue of Universal Design comes up
during our qualified allocation plan
meetings and I think the challenge is is
as a quasi public entity trying to
balance the extra cost with the unit
production uh because we're we're trying
to build units and um that's obviously
we're concerned about our disabled
brothers and sisters but if Universal
Design I don't know how much it adds
I'll find out so do you know if any of
the state programs um subsidize
Universal Design in their
programs I do not but I think it's it's
a fair question okay the other my my
other question is um who would you
recommend that we talk to um that
administers these um State um housing
trusts who who's in charge so in terms
of the hous level yeah on well on the
state level it's us we okay so basically
the state of New Hampshire is entitled
to the Housing Trust Fund dollars and
they have appointed New Hampshire
housing as the administrative entity for
dispersing those okay so we are speaking
to the if we wanted say some of this
money from the Housing Trust to go to
Universal Design
would we be able to do that or would it
have to come from one of the other state
programs like there's the affordable
housing trust I
know there was a whole list of them here
but but in terms you said because
because HUD you said is limited but um
you said we we need to rely on
state-based programs for some of this
yeah and I I if I if I understand your
question
it's a very interesting question and
again I'm just ignacious and the multif
family housing team about whether the
legislature could say you shall use a
percentage of your housing trust fund
dollars to to to do it Universal Design
um It's Complicated I mean you're adding
a layer of complexity but it's a fair
question and I can speak internally and
and we'll get back to you on that it
will mean less units and but if that's
the policy decision of the
legislature that's the decision and I
don't know how the
HUD so HUD HUD has so many like for us
to get it become the administer it's
pretty simple state says you administer
it whether the state can then impose
requirements on how it administer and
whether those line up with the federal
regs I'm going to have to do some
research on that okay
just repres the senator that was my
question I I felt like we'd have to
legally look into this because um that's
can be very complicated we'd have to
make sure we don't put forward
legislation that we haven't you know
dotted all the eyes and crossed the teas
and I I just wonder uh I this may be a
little bit of an ignorant question but
I'm thinking out loud is there a way
would it be legal or appropriate to
instead of taking taking these funds
that that are you've already mentioned
the different housing components
completely start a brand new way of
doing it specifically for this issue uh
like we started you know the invest New
Hampshire and then we did legislation on
housing Champions and would we be able
to start a whole just new funding
mechanism for this issue so my so again
not just speaking as Ignatius I mean
there already is the statute and I and
it's like 24
c57
24c 204 204 c c
57 which is the affordable housing fund
and if you're looking for a
mechanism that may be a mechanism where
you're not creating a brand new because
every time the government creates a new
approach it adds a level of complexity
to it and and I'm not speaking in favor
or against
this idea I'm just providing information
about that may be the mechanism if you
were looking to do it thank you I'm just
trying to figure out like how we're
going to proceed you know you know for a
solution okay we got two questions here
um representative L montine and then
representative
Ella I just want to go back you brought
up the project in nashaa so I'm trying
to get a sense of is it often a site
that comes to you and says says we want
to develop this site for affordable
housing will you then put out the bills
the start the whole bidding process and
let developers know we want someone to
build this it's a good question so as a
general rule we're New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority the
developers do that work so in that
particular case the city of nashaa says
to a developer neighbor work Southern
New Hampshire hey we have this lot could
you look into developing it so that's
that's the answer I will say that there
have been a few instances where New
Hampshire housing has owned land from
the state um where the on 90 95 where
the liquor store was going to be and I
believe it was Hampton we had a piece of
land that we did just that we put it out
to bid and Developers put forward
proposals that we then made a decision
okay we're going to sell the property to
this developer for this use but that's
not generally the way it works generally
the developers are in the communities
and finding where to build and and
working with the communities on that and
then they come to you for help with the
finance yes okay I'm representative
yella thank you um
from the housing that you currently
Finance do you know how many uh or what
percentage of the um the
units are uh meet the universal
design
standards if any well I can find out the
answer to that question um my guess
would be it's probably
not a significant number to go to your
earlier questions when you're trying to
control total development cost if you go
to Universal
Design um you're we're going to add to
those cost and that may be a decision
that's a good policy decision but that's
the kind of thing that we're weighing in
terms of trying to build the number of
units for the best cost um univer and I
like that question what would it cost to
to do Universal Design and we'll we'll
try to see if we can find an answer to
that question
thank you thank you so um I have another
question um which is something that
we've been hearing a lot about um Visa
part U Vis housing
um do parking
restrictions
um make a projects fail because they
don't pencil I mean when we're talking
about people with disabilities you know
if you're blind or you know you may have
a disability that prevents you from
driving um do you does every unit need
to parking
spaces that's my that's my question do
you find that that is a barrier to um
making projects
pencil the simple is answer is
everything that is a requirement impacts
whether the property is going to pencil
out I mean that's the bottom line if
you're doing two parking units you're
consuming land and then you're building
it and then you're maintaining it so
there's no question that the requirement
of parking spaces um drives up the
initial cost and the long-term
maintenance cost of the projects and I
believe um I believe New Hampshire
Housing and Jack may know is more
supportive of having a lower threshold
of of of spaces per unit uh because you
we have a lot of one-bedroom we have
senior housing and and if you have a
senior housing do you really need two
spaces all you're doing is driving up
cost that aren't really adding units so
I don't know Jack if you have any
comments has that been um has that been
a problem given local zoning
requirements well that issue was
addressed by the Senate um in the past
year um I think um through a bill that
might have been filed by Senator Perkins
quoka and there was um uh a fair amount
of negotiation with the towns because
the towns yes were very very concerned
about hey you know we want to be able to
set our own parking requirements and you
know the the
counterargument um from uh housing
Advocates was what inis just said which
is if they're unnecessarily burdensome
it
creates excess costs uh and and can
actually make a project financially
infeasible so I believe um that a bill
was signed into law that sets a limit of
one and a half parking spaces per unit
as a maximum um at the local level okay
the last thing I would say is a parking
space doesn't exist in space it exists
on the ground and a lot of the sites in
New Hampshire um require a lot of
engineering and a lot of working to get
density and every time you add a a
parking space you are impacting the
ability to have density on the housing
representa I believe the the bill you're
referring to is
hb400 which is uh a bill sponsored by uh
Miriam Williamson no uh Rebecca
Williamson Rebecca Williamson and and
myself oh yes um and we negotiated to I
think it's one and a half for
I I believe it's structures greater than
10 units I believe it's 10 units or
greater or something like that that the
Senate amended our the house version was
um no they're not allowed to require two
units or I think it was a maximum
requirement of one unit and it got
negotiated up to one and a half yeah
you're you're absolutely right on the
sponsorship I think I was confused
because at one point the home nebs Bill
may have gotten merged with 00 M and
then separated so I didn't know how it
it sort of all ended up but yes um
obviously um representative Mick
Williams and you yourself representative
one400 just look that
one I'm surprised you didn't ask that
question anyway okay so we have um all
right does anyone have any further
questions I see some folks from the
audience have have have wanted to speak
but um and you know if you could uh s
around and and do you have any do you
have any thoughts
on what what we can do to encourage more
disabilities what would be your just are
you asking of the audience or well I'm
asking of you guys at first well I I
guess what I would do is I would request
the opportunity to have have that
discussion internally because of the
integration of so many of these programs
um and if we if we do for example
Universal Design what does that mean and
I don't I can't run those numbers right
now but if you would give us that
opportunity we will provide our thoughts
is that fair Jack yeah so one of the
benefits of this um of this committee at
Senator Richard's request um we are
authorized to go for another year we'll
be um providing a preliminary report in
early November but then we have a full
year so we can um meet with people and
do deeper dives into these um into these
issues so thank you for offering that I
appreciate it so do you have anything
else you'd like to tell us okay so so
please stay around and we might call you
back up um because I see that there are
some people in the audience who have
some
thoughts all right thank you for the
opportunity to testify no thank you for
coming and um hope um hopefully on the
22nd we'll be hearing from some of some
developers New Hampshire housing um
action is working on finding some
nonprofit developers to come and talk to
us about these
coming thank you for the opportunity
great
okay so if if people from the audience
would like to uh ask a question or say
say something please come forward to the
name I just at Leisa Bodwin um I just
have one follow-up question from from
Senator Ricky 's question
um regarding the voucher program and I'm
wondering um if HUD has a
regulation that prevents New Hampshire
from contributing to the voucher
program um and or another way to put the
question is there a regulation or
mechanism for New Hampshire to
contribute funding to the voucher
program
that's a good
yes you don't think that's appropriate I
don't I think that in my in my opinion I
don't think that um we would do that
exactly in that mechanism I think that
what we would do if we were to do
something would be to essentially
earmark some
money um
and essenti
the requirements to get said Grant or
whatever would be that they be uh a
voucher holder or something like that
and therefore then that money would
essentially only go to those people that
had
voucher and so then you would be kind of
like helping essentially that um it was
also kind of something that I was
thinking about as far as like if we knew
the difference between um the cost to
build a house you know is it 10% more to
go to um Universal Design or something
maybe there was some mechanism that knew
that that the um New Hampshire
legislature would be willing to earmark
some money that would say hey if you had
a
project um you know we're willing
to um if you have a project of you know
five units or 10 units we're willing to
put up that you know half of that 10% or
whatever if you're going to make it
Universal design or something and justk
some money specifically to help
incentiv the Universal Design which then
would those units might be able to be
better suited to address
the disabled populations
right so I so I guess my question D
is what could the state give you money
for vouchers that's the question yes and
okay Senator I just keep thinking about
how all these people are on these
ridiculous weight lists and I keep going
back to what you said about somebody
terminally ill it's absolutely
ridiculous and I call this an
emergency this is an
emergency I think one of the things I
didn't mention is can you come to the
microphone please because we're we're on
uh one of the things I maybe should have
mentioned when I talk about attrition
the average weight time of a voucher
participant on the program is 11 to 12
years wow okay so if you don't have
turnover nutrition you have a set number
of subsidies by the federal government
you can't go over 4,000 you know or
whatever the number may be and if
there's very little turnover because
once someone has a voucher they hold on
to that and if um you someone has
extremely low
income they're probably going to have
extremely low income for 10 12 years you
know unless they're working towards um
getting off the program or participating
in some of our family selfs efficiency
programs or or they're working you know
and they want to um graduate themselves
off the program otherwise the length of
grown followup so while they're in this
waiting period this endless waiting
period where are they what are they
doing another good
question we ask when they come to the
top of the waiting list uh we have to
report to HUD if they um are homeless
when they get to the top and unless
that's the only question we really ask
them but most of them share or will tell
us they were either you know staying
with friends and family doubling up um
living in substandard housing not paying
other bills to pay their
by
yeah so unfortunately now what we have
to say to a lot of colle
is the voucher is not an immediate
available resource for many it's it's
it's Federal program and that's how it
is
funded what do you think about the idea
of the
state um providing funding for owners of
substandard housing say will help will
provide money to rehab this if you agree
to accept Section 8 vouchers or if you
agree to convert it to Universal Design
is there there have been some home for
all see Coast United Way had a a
program something like that where they
had a certain amount of funds that they
would for landlords who would um be part
I don't know everything about their
program but if a landlord wanted to be
part of their program they would give
them some money maybe for an in
incentive fee for some repairs maybe
damages mitigation fund and in return
they would rent to a a voucher
holder
um
possible um I I guess one one final
question that that that I have well I
keep saying that but um there are other
programs like 79e which is for you know
uh downtown buildings that are um
underutilized Etc
who who Who's in charge of
that do do we know no no is it the local
municipalities but there's the
okay
okay can you come to the microphone
okay so 79 E vouchers which allow
municipalities to provide tax credits
for yes so RSA
79e um essentially is tax deferral um
for new projects uh and recently uh
among the uses um could be for uh
conversion of I think um uh business
properties into housing residential
housing um but there's no sort of
Statewide program with an administrator
it is simply a tax incentive that towns
May opt to uh apply to a given project
in in their own
town um would are are there any
um are there any prohibitions
against what would need to happen for
towns to
include um Universal Design as um a
um as an attribute of a project that
would allow the town to provide this tax
incentive do would we have to change the
law
yeah I don't think so but I am not an
expert in this area and I can definitely
go back to the office and ask um someone
who's got more expertise in this area
all right I appreciate that you have
have some thoughts you've worked a lot
on this Housing St yeah 79e I think if
some I think that you would need to
change the 79e to specifically State
like hey you're allowed to um because
it's essentially kind of like a list of
things that the municipality is allowed
to provide um tax incentives for and so
if you wanted to add another one then
you would need to add it to
79e um or
or kind of say for example the one that
just got recently added to change
commercial um you know office space
into uh housing if you could say as long
as it you know comma as long or as long
as it meets Universal Design and that
would then limit the municipality to
only providing that benefit to those
that were Universal Design or you could
go the other way and say say a specific
or you know they can do um given a
increased um incentive to those that
meet Universal Design or something like
that but I think all of those language
changes would be within 79 E thank you
thank you yeah okay all right is there
anything else are there oh yes come
forward hi Will Walker Hollis uh thank
you very much thank you New Hampshire
housing for all the information today
outstanding presentation you guys have
helped me a lot in my own exploration in
the space I do have one request because
you guys were taking on so much already
um as you were looking at the
incremental cost to do Universal Design
from building um I'm also wondering can
you do a research into what it cost to
rehab a place to make it
accessible um we in in working in
software accessibility for decades we
often found that retrofitting something
was far more expensive than doing it
right the first
you okay one thing that I failed to do
um on on the agenda was for us to um
approve the minutes of the previous
meeting
um they're right here do I have a motion
to approve the minutes
think I got you didn't get one of these
okay sorry about that I
wasn't okay so if you want to take a
minute to do that and
uh I read them earlier I read them L
I mean on
on on what is this it's not it's
one
[Music]
one wow 1
a
uh Roman
4 number
five or maybe it's Roman 5 a uh uh or or
no Roman 6 where I said um I was asking
if if the statistics they that they were
giving were for people with intellectual
disabilities or just people that were
just generally disabled the answer was
that they were only specifically giving
us uh information about people with in
intellectual disabilities it had nothing
to do with people with physical
disabilities so I don't know that answer
was using ID as example really yeah I
think I meant to get back to that but I
okay it didn't have good notes on it so
but thank you you'll have a recording
this time to work that would be helpful
yeah okay that that's the only thing I
see that jumps out so otherwise I I'm
happy to a motion to approve these um
with adjusting that that answer
okay um I guess I will second
that I'm allowed to second right sure
you can you want all right all those in
favor I by saying I okay okay and one
exstension
CH okay all right um then um if there's
nothing further I um ask for a motion to
adjourn so
move do I have a second I'll second okay
all right motion by Senator richardi
second by representative yella all those
in favor say I I okay meeting adjourned